Of course,
a lot of universities are looking for
partners in India and a faculty
exchanges,
student exchanges.
These are enormously beneficial also to
India.
Uh,
I think the important development that
has happened in America,
to my mind,
is that all the major universities are
setting up India study centers,
or they will have an Indian studies
initiative as Howard has a,
Yale has started to offer a major in
South Asian studies,
but 90% of South Asian studies is really
Indian studies.
Berkeley and Stanford have had
longstanding collaborations.
A number of business schools are being
set up in collaboration with American
institutions.
The Indian School of Business in
Hyderabad,
in collaboration with Kellogg has
already,
after just five years of its founding,
uh,
become one of the top 20 schools in the
world.
So that's the kind of
dynamics,
which is very exciting for us.